sí muy buenas tardes pues el homenaje a
esta ceremonia homenaje nacional debe
comenzar sobre las 7 30 de la noche hora
de parís pero antes de esto el
presidente de manuela mccomb va a
entrevistarse con la familia de samuel
para ti y será ahí donde le entregará la
legión de honor que es la distinción más
alta que pueda dársele a alguien en
francia y además de esto también será
nombrado el comandante de las palmas
académicas esta es una distinción
también pues muy ligada al mundo de la
enseñanza y luego de esto si comenzará
esta ceremonia que será en el patio
central de la sorbona un lugar muy
simbólico en francia porque pues es
digamos como el templo de la enseñanza y
al mismo tiempo pues está estrechamente
ligado con el siglo de las luces habrá
unos 400 invitados claramente en medio
de toda esta epidemia de coronavirus
pues todos tendrán que estar
con distancia acción social con
mascarilla dentro de estos invitados
estarán algunos miembros del gobierno ex
presidentes habrá 100 invitados que
vendrán de colegios entre profesores y
estudiantes de colegios de la región
isla de francia en la cual se encuentra
también a parís y el consejo del culto
musulmán en francia también ya dijo que
formará parte de esta de esta de este
homenaje en el día de hoy habrá
pantallas gigantes tanto cerca de la
sorbona como del panteón para que las
personas afuera puedan seguir la
ceremonia sin natalia le pregunto cómo
van las investigaciones sobre lo
ocurrido y qué es lo último que se sabe
sobre la orden de disolver la
organización sheik de assín
así es digamos que esto es como la
información digamos de este día es la
disolución de esta organización
propalestina y cuyo fundador abdel hakim
más safavi está en manos de o está en
poder de las autoridades es una de las
personas que todavía están en custodia
de la policía el gobierno considera que
esta asociación pues tuvo una
implicación directa en la muerte de
assam ya la patita dentro de toda esta
investigación 16 personas estuvieron
digamos pues fueron interrogadas por la
policía pero ahora solamente el 7 que
hoy deberían o van a ser presentadas a
un juez antiterrorista se habrá
seguramente una imputación de cargos
dentro de estas siete personas además de
este islamista activista en visitante
islamista radical ya que como lo
explican acá habrá también dos menores
de edad que aseguran que al parecer
ahora no habían recibido dinero para dar
información acerca del profesor y
también un padre de familia y tres
personas más que conocían al atacante
dentro de dos horas habrá una
conferencia de prensa de la fiscal
general antiterrorista en francia